what surprise weapon Finity today we're
playing a game to 21 points with these
different items with each point you win
you move on to the next part first point
is with a normal racket good luck thanks
also zr0
[Applause]
oh sorry
oh yeah now I get the deepest I'm stuck
with my own ok penhold Mundi
[Music]
No
oh come on
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh you started to move me all right yeah
of course
[Applause]
yes it's still heavy
yes
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
slow lucky lucky again no surprise there
[Music]
[Music]
badminton is my point
I think so too no that's so bad
[Music]
I'm starting to feel bad about my lucky
ball I'm so sorry
[Music]
[Applause]
ah this is to draw always going for this
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
No
I saw the waters coming coming straight
to the edge okay dumbbell
[Applause]
mmm smash with the dumbbell
yeah
[Music]
good yes I hate this ruler calling
[Applause]
close how did you play with this
[Music]
[Applause]
no tempted to eat this one no chance to
get that one yes no more chair for me no
this is my number one sir Oh finally I
cut something here with this fork
no that's close
no the stairs Eames this is the match
who's been waiting for ya and vs. pen
good feeling in a pen no 2-point
difference okay service on the table yo
easy thanks ace that's right
okay so that was fun the pen was maybe a
bit too difficult
yeah it was really hard don't forget to
hit subscribe and watch our previous
videos there until next time